well let's talk about gender because uh
you uh
you studied insects i guess right i did
insect evolutionary biology social
behavior animal personality
yeah uh did that include studying the
like
behavior of the different sexes and like
mating rituals and stuff not so much so
i studied social spiders
mainly for my dissertation and their
colonies were almost entirely female
there's like a ten to one uh okay older
female
well so ratio so anyway you're you're
you have a phd right yeah okay we'll
just ignore everything else and we'll
just say phd from now on everything you
say is academic boom expert we'll just
he's got a phd therefore listen to what
he has to say yeah exactly oh but no no
i think it's a we
we can talk about the gender thing too
because now we're it's not just about
race
they do the exact same thing to gender
they've taken the word gender and
they've they've beaten it to a to a
point where it's unrecognizable and i
don't even know what they're trying to
say anymore
because at first they said that oh no
gender and sex are different things
you know sex is biology but gender
is social construct now they're saying
there's no biological sex
i mean they've been saying that for
years but you know that's where we've
gotten yeah i mean those are like the
second wave feminists who are
they wanted to deconstruct gender as
like the social construction that keeps
males and females
playing these certain roles in society
but they definitely wanted to keep
a very strong notion of biological sex
because sex was
the the object it was the physical
entity that people are identified
that you can use that to then
discriminate people you know people are
discriminated against because of the
perceived sex that they are and this was
something that
you know the second wave feminists were
very aware of
but now we see this like third wave
intersectional feminism
where they're blurring the boundaries
between sex and gender they're the same
thing or they're different depending on
the context and
how they want to win an argument right
yeah and
they've completely de-centered
biological sex from
the talk of of women's rights so now we
can't even talk about the
actual basis of the oppression of
certain individuals based on their sex
because
now it's just a state of mind but you
know for all you know i could be
gender fluid i could be going back and
forth between male and female in my mind
well in the first segment you were a
dude then you were a woman now you're
back to being a dude
i mean it just switched again yeah so
you know but there's nothing that
changes physically about me you can't
see it and so
the idea that we can actually that we
should be centering a state of your
mind of how you feel about yourself in
relation to your body as
the objective of oppression just makes
absolutely no sense
i think you said something they want to
win an argument it's almost like they're
toddlers
you know like their their their their
their mental maturity is that of
a seven-year-old who's like you're dumb
no i'm smart that's racist no you're not
allowed to say it uh-uh yeah
that's how it manifests itself is very i
mean they have so much snark
in their arguments it's just they get
brownie points for how snarky they are
uh but it also boils down to sort of
this
um what would i call it gender critical
theory
um mainly queer theory is what they're
using to just try to blur the boundaries
between
male and female because again you can
kind of keep going back and you see
these certain themes
they think that there's power dynamics
just by the fact that you're
categorizing things
male and female are these real entities
well no this is just a
you know white western notion of how you
know people try to
oppress certain groups by maintaining
these binaries and forcing people into
them
so that's that's sort of where we are
right now in terms of
third wave feminism and gender and sex i
think we may be reaching a point where i
don't know if the critical gender theory
people can
actually pass this and
it is you think they'll be able to just
keep going and doing whatever they want
or i don't think so
because it's one of those things i mean
i've said it before that
this is one of one of the last tests for
for reality it's like reality's last
stand in a way
if we can if we can convince a large
swath of america
or humanity that there's no such thing
as male and female
then you can just maybe roll ahead and
get anything you want in there because
it's one of the most things that i think
well luckily almost
everyone who's not super woke leftist
realizes that male and female
are different almost everyone on their
right is going to acknowledge the fact
that males and females are real and
different
probably most people on the left as well
especially in the realm of sports i
think that's where it's going to
really show i look i look at like
the younger generation and and there's
like uh
a left-wing meme that mocks the the
rights
fifth grade twenty-year-old
understanding of biology
and the the the the angle they're taking
is
science is supposed to change because we
learn more
and we heard it from bill nye on netflix
we learned a whole lot now it's
a spectrum and not there's not male and
female it's like
male female male you know just like
weird gradient between the two huh
i'm going to say i think we're reaching
a point where there's going to be
systems in place that are going to be
very difficult to overcome
so uh one example wikipedia wikipedia is
a
structure it functions in a specific way
you can't use many of these broken
definitions
because you need to be able to say word
means this and link to another word
and it has to be a a it's it's basically
like you're looking at an actual
structure of a building
you can't just randomly place things the
building won't stand
if the building is already there you
can't move blocks out
so i'll give you an example this is the
wikipedia page for woman
a woman is an adult female human end of
story
what's a female well female is
specifically defined as
it is a sex of an organism or part of an
organism that produces non-mobile ova
egg cells barring rare medical
conditions most female mammals including
humans have two x chromosomes
so wikipedia you can't just go and look
they even locked the page isn't this
crazy
this it's semi-protected probably
because people bombarded
yup trying to change it here's the
problem
ask any one of these critical gender
theorists what's a defined woman
oh they can't do it right because woman
is adult human female
what would they say it is they would say
a woman is
anyone who lives and identifies as a
woman and then when you drill down on
that well how does a woman
live and identify well then they just
get into certain
stereotypes of masculinity and
femininity and then all of a sudden
they'll insist that they're not it's not
based on stereotypes whenever you drill
down
on saying like what do you how what does
it mean to live as one what does it mean
to identify as one
or express yourself as one it boils down
to
stereotypes this is progressive
conservative stereotypes
it's backwards interesting this is why i
think a lot
of so a lot of what we see i was reading
about
rapid onset gender dysphoria you're
familiar with this yeah
and they there was one study i was
reading i think it got pulled actually
i'm not sure that it said that like
paper i don't know which one but they
said 85 percent
of trans children are female to male did
you read that yeah
is this just i'm going to say it
internalized misogyny
because here's what i got to say they
talk about stereotypes
right that you know a woman can look
wherever she wants right
some women have facial hair it just
happens and they're still women right
and so you have a bunch of young women
who are calling themselves male names
dressing in in male stereotypical ways
almost like a caricature of a man
and i wonder if they just hate women and
they hate womanhood
and it's not about being trans or
non-binary it's about literally just
hating femininity and loving masculinity
i think there's some of that i mean if
you're going to define gender identity
ultimately boils down to differences in
stereotypes then you get to this point
where you have children growing up
they're told these ideas that being a
man or woman or even male or female
because these are the same thing now
uh is based on gender stereotypes now
you've got get a tomboy
who has more male typical behaviors like
to hang out with boys like rough and
tumble
all that stuff now suddenly they're
questioning their gender identity now
suddenly there's like well i'm i have
these i'm more stereotypically
male in my behaviors and then some of
this gender theory
tells them that you might be a boy
i mean nowadays they're saying you are
you are yeah or at least you're highly
suspect so you get a lot of lesbians who
also
are very much correlated with gender
atypical behavior more
more male-like behavior and so you're
basically getting the situation where
you have
a lot of young lesbians showing up to
these gender clinics that are
saying that i think i'm a boy because i
have when they list all these
male typical behaviors and then in some
states you can just
you know you can get your puberty
blockers or your your hormones right
right across the uh
yeah right over the counter so the
wikipedia thing is really interesting to
me because
right now there's a debate right they
say why
you call whatever you want trans women
are women right
that's that's what the left says not
according to wikipedia
according to wikipedia because you have
to have clear definitions of what both
of those things are
so when you're talking about someone who
is
assigned male at birth and then
identifies as female and undergoes
transition
that is classified on wikipedia as trans
woman
so if you ask these people they'll say
no that's a woman i'm sorry
woman is defined on wikipedia as an
adult human female meaning they produce
barring rare medical uh conditions i'm
actually shocked that wikipedia is
hasn't been corrupted i would expect
that to i don't think it can that's that
that's the problem that's where i think
the wall is being hit
because you can't have one word linked
to two articles
so how do how does the system functional
consistency is not
well they're strong suits so i don't
exactly imagine they might not care at
some point
well no that's not the issue the issue
is wikipedia is a digital structure
logical consistency is mandatory for its
function to a certain degree
they could probably create a hybrid
article and say a woman
is anyone who claims to be a woman but
then what's female but then because they
have to address the idea of male and
female but they're already arguing it
doesn't exist
how will that impact plants and insects
for instance yeah
well we have very very like we were
talking about this before the show the
anglerfish
right so i don't realize it's the angler
they're the ones with the weird little
doodads on their heads
that's so funny they have like lights on
their faces or whatever that's cool
so basically the the female is massive
and nasty looking
yeah and the male is a little nasty
looking thing and it
latches to the female bites them and
then just becomes a permanent attachment
to the female
weird and then just deposits you know
sperm and stuff
into the females constantly constantly
okay
so when you see that biological sex
literally exists in nature very
obviously so there's a clash then
on personal identity if they try and go
into wikipedia and
change female and male because they want
to get rid of it
that would shatter the that would
shatter the systems already created
around
our mapping of biology it can't humanity
is tied to the animal kingdom
you can't just claim male and female
doesn't don't exist because we can see
it expressed in ridiculous ways across
the animal kingdom
i mean cardinals for instance you have
the bright red cardinal and then the
little
red female yeah yeah you have this
conflation
among the activists where they try to
look at they conflate
sexual dimorphism which is you know
different features that males and
females have
with sex itself okay so if you were to
look at something like the gender-bred
person that they have
what what is what is the gender
breadboard so it's it's this
poster that they have in certain schools
i've heard that it's even being
used in some college courses on in
gender studies
uh where it lists basically it has this
gender bread gingerbread bread person uh
and then a label
like it highlights different areas on
the on the body like
gender and it'll have it in their head
like how you identify then it has a
little box that says
biological sex and it's pointing to you
know the crotch of the gender bread
person
and in that in that crotch area where it
breaks down biological sex it will list
things like
voice pitch body hair things like that
well these have nothing actually to do
with your ex what sex you are so the
biggest conflation
is conflating primary sexual
characteristics with secondary ones
they'll try to say that if you are an
individual and you have a beard
and you have you know more upper body
strength and you have a deep voice
they're trying to say that you're
actually more male
if you have those traits even if you're
biologically a female
so i try to use i use an analogy that's
it's like
it's like bikers and cyclists okay like
if you define a biker
as someone who rides a motorcycle and a
cyclist is someone who rides a bicycle
these are two different types of
vehicles okay they're very different
ones motorized has gas
once you pedal uh but then you can also
say well what are the secondary traits
of bikers and cyclists
and the secondary trade of a biker would
be you know leather pants
skull tattoos bandanas you know smoking
cigarettes whatever all those things
and you look at bikers or cyclists and
their secondary characteristics are
spandex bodies
and those weird helmets weird helmets
you know probably more clean shaven
they shave their whole body or whatever
you do like these are vegan
these are so i'm not sure that one make
sense like those are like secondary
traits that are associated with being
cyclists
and bikers but if you were to have
someone riding a motorcycle
who's wearing a spandex bodysuit and you
know all the stuff a cyclist typically
wears
they wouldn't magically become a cyclist
they would still be a biker because
they're writing a bicycle that's a good
way to put a motorcycle you can have the
secondary sex characteristics
of males or female that doesn't have
anything to say about what your actual
biological sex is which has to do with
what is the uh reproductive anatomy that
you have what
has it been organized around the
production of
of sperm or ova you don't actually have
to make sperm or ova to be
a male or female but what is your
reproductive anatomy
how is it developed what is it centered
around the production i like that well
so so
all that stuff in mind there's how do
you create how do you take
the the existing scientific
infrastructure and and
i mean wikipedia is a great example
specifically because you click words to
link to articles if you can't
change the article and have one word
mean two things
that's the key component of the critical
race theorists of the of the the
critical gender theorists is having one
word mean multiple things at the same
time
yeah well they're against the any
categorization whatsoever so
so wikipedia is just gonna go so
wikipedia would probably make their own
wikipedia
wikipedia that's a good one that'd be a
funny one to make we should get that
domain
seriously someone just bought it
wokepedia someone probably got it
already but you could do all satire and
like actually no you could actually
break down the absurdity of
their beliefs in a way that's kind of
what james lindsay's new discourses
is it's basically well he calls it
translations from the wokish
oh yeah yeah it's basically wikipedia
yeah so i i've seen
um i think it was uh heather heing and
brett weinstein talk about this
they like that sex is bimodal have you
have you heard that
i've heard that i don't agree with that
statement but uh
the the what they often show when they
say that is that
you know 99 of males and females fall
within a very specific range
but there is an extreme that slightly
cross each other in terms of
like estrogen or or testosterone or
masculinity or femininity
they don't connect though so the idea is
you can have a male
who is more stereotypically female and
effeminate
than the average female but still be
producing sperm and being male
they don't connect they're just two
different independent trees
that can surpass each other on a scale
of feminine femininity to masculinity
but what the left does is they say it's
a spectrum and they connect them
yeah so as though that at some point you
actually switch to the other side and
your body starts producing the other
you know yeah so if you're looking at
like the secondary
sex characteristics like breast size and
facial hair and
body weight or whatever those are very
bimodal like they're
correlated with sex but they're not
definitional and of sex
but then there's this other structure
underneath of sex which is
basically the binary male or female
even though the secondary traits can
sort of map on over the top of that
i usually use it as like i could do like
a coin flip analogy
uh because you know you have heads and
tails on a coin
about one out of every six thousand
flips with a nickel will land on its
edge is that true
yeah six thousand have a study wow
and that's almost the exact same rate of
intersex individuals that
are in the population that have somewhat
ambiguous genitalia that might not be
easily classifiable as
as male or female not always but
sometimes it can be pretty ambiguous
so what a lot of the trans activists try
to say is the existence of these
intersex individuals these one out of
five or six thousand individuals they're
calling to the
into question the existence of males or
females
well that's kind of like saying that
just because a coin can land on its edge
that means that heads and tails are not
real discrete
outcomes so right male and female
they're discreet outcomes you're
if you're a male you're just as much as
male as a male who's got a weaker beard
who's not as tall who's got a light
a high voice there's not like more or
less male there you're just
it's it's a discrete category even
though we can acknowledge that there is
an edge someone might land on the edge
where they could have ovo testes they
might not they
be they're infertile they don't produce
either sperm or ova they have ambiguous
genitalia
and who's going to say whether this
individual is male or female i don't
think
maybe in some instances you can't quite
assign them to
them it's one of the things they
actually bring up because
there are some people who are intersex
who look like they're male
or look like they're female but they're
intersex yeah and there's a bunch of
different you know
most inner sex conditions are sex
specific um
which a lot of people don't tend to
realize like what do you mean by that
so like um let's say like caster sumenya
for instance
she has a um a condition called five a
rd which she has
uh basically so real quick who is she oh
she's the south african
um runner basically the olympic of
runner and she's recently been
banned from competing in the olympic and
some in some events because
uh she was you know assigned
female at birth but she has a condition
to basically make it so
your male genitals don't develop when
you're
in utero so you're basically born and
you can
look your genitals can look
stereotypically all female
to sometimes they can also look male
depending on how severe um your case is
and so she was presumably has more
feminine looking genitalia because she
was
marked down as female at birth but her
condition is a condition only affects
biological males so she has interesting
she's xy she has internal testes that's
why her
testosterone level is so high that she
can't compete in these leagues because
they have certain rules
for athletes who have her specific
condition but did they used to
like did they they didn't use them they
just be like you look like a woman
congratulations you can run yeah
there's a whole history of of how
people were banned and kept out of
certain categories for the you know the
woman's category
and there's some horror stories of you
know what people were subject to back in
the day as well but
um people try to make make it that they
say that cement is
you know she's a woman she's a female
that's what people say but no one ever
really brings up the fact that cement is
actually
xy and has testes um is it is it fair to
say biologically male in that capacity
or is it
i would say biologically male um
interesting people with her condition
have fathered children before
so if that puts it into perspective well
the only thing that really matters is
everyone is deserving of the same equal
rights under the constitution in our
country and human rights in the world
period
and i think that's that's one of the
things they try to use to make it seem
like conversations like this are meant
to attack an individual's rights or
anything like that and it's not
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you